this video is about the story of elven
ring this will cover all the important
characters relevant to the main story
including most bosses and some npcs as
well as explain what happened before we
arrive in the lands between who we play
as and what the endings of the game mean
sections of this video are separated via
chapters located on the timeline should
you need to re-watch a specific section
again as always spoiler warning ahead if
you haven't beaten elven ring i highly
recommend you do that and then come back
as everything after this point will be
spoiler territory with that out of the
way like the video if you enjoy and
let's get started
so the location of eldon ring is in a
place called the lands between this is a
land ruled by a queen america it was
once ruled by a dragonlord but it said
that when its god abandoned them they
sat in slumber awaiting their return
which left the spot for the ruler open
this title was given to her by someone
known as the greater will when you
become the ruler of the lands between
you also become a vessel for the elven
ring the elven ring is the single most
powerful thing in the lands between its
power is what created the archery and it
is meant to uphold different concepts
like life death space and many others it
also defines the logic of the world
called the golden order which is a law
the residents of the lands between abide
by the greater will is an outer god and
it's said to have sent down a star that
held a beast that would later become the
elden ring the elden beast the final
boss of the game is defined as a vassal
for the greater will and the living
embodiment of the concept of order to
become the ruler of the lands between
the ruler will need three things they
need to be an emperian and must have a
consort and a shadow a consort is just
the spouse that they marry who in
america's case was godfrey a shadow is
the protector of that ruler and an
emperian is someone who is born from a
single god talking with ronnie towards
the end of her questline reveals that
her mykola and melania are considered
emperians
let us speak of the past a while
i was once an imperial
of the demigods
only i
mickeler and melania could claim that
title
each of us was chosen by our own two
fingers
as a candidate to succeed queen america
to become the new god of the coming age
that means there is a clear distinction
between a demigod like godric and an
empyrean like melania melania mikala and
ronnie are still considered demigods but
there is that empyrean part of them that
separates them from the rest the
question though is how is this possible
so when america became the first ruler
she wasn't fond of the idea of death in
her land so she removed the rune of
death from the elven ring and forced it
onto her shadow who was meliketh instead
of protecting her as the shadow would
she betrayed him and just used him as a
way to keep the death away from her land
with the rune of death out of the elden
ring it allowed america and many others
to gain immortality shortly after this
she needed a consort who would then be
godfrey and now that godfrey was her
husband he also received the title of
elden lord making him the first elden
lord this isn't entirely true as there
is a lore that does suggest the very
first elden lord was possibly dragon
lord plaxitus that we fight in pharah
missoula but i think either no one knew
of the dragonlord or godfrey was the
first elden lord during his own age
which was the age of the urgery which
was much later than when placidus was
eldenlord regardless godfrey and merica
had two kids which were godwin and
godric this is easily identifiable
thanks to the god prefix and their names
there were more kids besides them but
more on them later during this time war
had been going on against the golden
order and another person named ratigan
had been involved in the conflict but
decided to usher peace by marrying lady
ranala queen of the carrion royal family
when the two were together they ended up
having children as well being named
radon riker and ronnie once again all of
them start with an r just like radigan
and ranala's first name after the
warhead finished it was said that the
hue of godfrey's eyes had faded possibly
meaning he had served his purpose and
was no longer needed as soon after he
was exiled and became the very first
tarnished but now america is without a
consort so she sought out radigan
radigan then left ranala and joined
america at the urgery and became her new
husband and the new elden lord and since
he was an elden lord his children by
proxy were allowed to be a part of the
royal family which is why they have
thrones at the royal capital despite not
being america's offspring once again
ratigan and merica were together and
they had even more kids that being the
twins mikola and melania this may stir
up some confusion as i just mentioned
that an empyrean has to be born from a
single god yet rani mikala and melania
were all born by two parents well as we
discover later in the game america is
ratigan there's a statue in lindell that
has a riddle that says regression alone
reveals secrets by using the spell laws
of regression in front of the statue it
changes its form and the text changes to
radigan ismerica now i'll be completely
honest it has never explained how this
happened and what exactly this means and
it's probably the biggest question that
has been unanswered so far in the
community some have come up with some
theories regarding this such as the two
being separate entities who refuse
together somehow or it's one body that
suffers from dissociative identity
disorder however the other question that
remains is who was first although i do
believe there is an answer to this given
the empyrean status and the greater will
giving her the lands between i think
queen merica was first but this riddle
now explains why ratigan left ronaldo
for america and why mikola and millennia
are considered emperian since their
parents are the same person which then
fits the rules of that one god
stipulation this has been quite the
family tree so a huge shout out to just
ambling on on reddit for creating this
easy to read graphic the only outliers
here at the moment are america's parents
but seeing as she's an emperian it's not
as simple to answer plus we get zero
info on her parents anyway but besides
them the only one left is malacath
america's shadow and the keeper of the
rune of death according to his armor
description malakath is actually her
half-brother who wielded a blade imbued
with the rune of death this is a good
time to explain this as if you noticed
from the actual description it says
destined death well the finger reader at
the round table hold clarifies that the
rune of death goes by two names and the
other is destined death the rune of
death goes by two names
the other
is destined death
the forbidden shadow plucked from the
golden order upon its creation for
simplicity's sake unless entirely
necessary i will refer to it as just the
rune of death to avoid any further
confusion the final character of this
family tree we haven't thoroughly talked
about is ronnie earlier in the game a
witch known as rena meets with us
however this is ronnie she's just using
a different name in order to disguise
her identity ronnie was born under
ranala and radigan two separate people
yet is considered an emperian it's still
not clear as to why this is the case but
my only working theory is that ranala is
her adoptive mother but we'll discuss
that in the boss's chapter regardless
it's not that big of a deal anyway since
she didn't want to be an empyrean this
sequence of events would eventually lead
to the shattering
depending on who you ask the shattering
might be considered the greatest war
ever fought or the worst tragedy the
land has ever seen ronnie wanting to be
anything but an empyrean worked against
marika the greater will and the two
fingers and devised a plan one day she
stole the rune of death from malacate
with that power she created daggers able
to kill the demi-gods on that same night
called the knight of the black knives a
group of assassins called the black
knife assassins would kill the first
demigod godwin it's also interesting to
note here that according to the black
knife armor description all of the
members of this group were women and
they're all rumored to be newman which
you may remember as one of the default
races in the character creation they
also have close ties to america which
may mean that america is of newman
descent it doesn't really give us much
regarding her backstory but it is worth
knowing anyway back to the intro when
godwin was killed he had a mark on his
body this is considered the curse mark
of death an item we could receive during
ronnie's questline this curse mark
appeared the moment godwin was killed
but this symbol however is incomplete as
it should have been a full circle the
reason it's only half is because two
demigods died at the same time breaking
the curse into half circles the other
god was ronnie herself as ronnie says
she wanted to strip away her imperian
flesh so that nothing of her was related
to the two fingers both of these
demigods had the opposite happen to them
ronnie's body was dead but her soul
lived on and godwin's soul was destroyed
but his body survived this not only
explains why ronnie's new body is a doll
but also why godwin was seemingly reborn
after he was killed godwin was given the
name the prince of death because of this
encounter and is related to fia's
questline where she tries to resurrect
him after hearing the news of godwin's
death america possibly in a fit of rage
shattered the elden ring one thing to
remember of course is the distinction
between radigan and merika because
america's hammer reads the tool with
which queen america shattered the elven
ring and red again attempted to repair
it this is once again left up to the
community to decide as it's never
explained but my working theory and
furthermore my theory between ratigan
and merica is that originally they were
separate people but something fused them
together possibly the greater will in
regards to the shattering situation i
think each of them despite being the
same person act differently which
explains why america specifically broke
the ring and why ratigan specifically is
trying to repair it with the shards of
the elder rings scattered everywhere
across the lands between all the
demigods were attempting to gather all
the shards the intro then shows a
slideshow of some of the demigods like
mo the lord of blood taking mykola away
a serpent biting a helmet which is
related to reichard symbolizing how he
became the lord's serpent and then the
iconic fight between melania and radon
the problem is that during this war
nobody won the land was stuck in a
stalemate with the demigods that were
left standing holding pieces of the
elven ring but nobody was close to
owning all of them this stalemate left
things unchanged and the land was
covered in ruins with some areas like
khalid being covered in rotten disease
furthermore none of the demigods are
making moves on each other as they
preferred to defend their land rather
than fight to take others land and
subsequently the shards so something was
needed to break this stalemate which is
where we come in
we are called tarnished during the age
before the shattering called the age of
the earth tree the golden power of the
earth tree would drop down from its
branches and spread across the lands
between it blessed many throughout the
land but also refused to bless others
for an unknown reason these people were
considered tarnished those who aren't
worthy of the urgery and are looked down
upon by the eyes of the golden order
this exile we received is similar to
godfrey's exile as he was deemed useless
by the greater will and the golden order
which is symbolized by him losing the
golden color in his eyes we are deemed
unworthy by the greater will so it has
no use for us in the lands between which
means we're considered tarnished and are
forced to leave but when the shattering
occurred the lands between was in
disarray and because it still wanted to
hold onto its power the greater will
bless the previously exiled tarnished in
hopes that it will return and restore
the golden order it was even able to
bless many tarnished who are dead like
us of the other tarnished the important
ones listed in the intro are horulu
chieftain of the badlands the brilliant
gold mask via the deathbed companion the
loathsome dung eater and gideon off near
the all-knowing our objective as this
new tarnished is to cross the fog back
into the lands between stand before the
elven ring and become the elven lord the
key here however is elden lord not the
ruler meaning we are never meant to use
serp merica from her position merely
bring the runes together so that
everything can go back to normal
confer great rules to become elden lord
and join queen america as her consort
the fingers
have willed its soul
this however did not happen thanks to us
committing the very first cardinal sin
later in the game which was the burning
of the archery and more on that a bit
later so as a tarnished resident of the
lands between we are eagerly ready to
take on the demigods until we're killed
by the first enemy we face but we are
somehow able to get back up again avare
right at the beginning of the game
explains that the guidance of grace the
same light that guides us towards the
bosses in game is what gives us
tarnished life meaning it can revive us
it's also possible that the rune of
death also affects us too since the
removal of the rune made people immortal
in the lands between which may explain
our revival for those who don't know
most if not all the soulsborne games
always had a reason as to why death was
canon so it's hard to believe that it
wouldn't exist in elven ring 2. after
exploring the lands between will run
into melinda the girl from earlier in
the intro she tells us that she will
become our finger maiden since we are
maidenless except later she apologizes
that she isn't actually a maiden so she
offers us a deal if we can continue to
work with her and bring her to the foot
of the er tree so that she can meet with
her mother and discover her purpose she
will continue to act as our maiden and
allow us to level up there's a lot more
to melania's story but i'll save that
for later when we discuss the endings
after some time she will then introduce
us to the round table hold the covert
operation base for the two fingers and a
place where tarnished champions guided
by grace can reside most of them however
don't seem too keen on becoming elden
lord in fact it only really feels like
us and gideon are really working towards
that goal many of them just seem to want
to save shelter away from the danger
outside according to gideon we aren't
going to get a proper welcome into the
round table though until we defeat
ashard bear and the first one we can
defeat is godric but before we meet
godric we have to talk about market
margaret the fel omen is a recurring
character in the game as he not only
shows up again in the altus plateau but
also shows up at the foot of the herd
tree under the name morgoth the omen
king earlier i talked about children we
haven't discussed yet and that is morgot
and moe if you remember from before we
talked about how michela and melania are
twins this is the same with morgan and
mo godrick's great rune says that elven
lord godfrey and his offspring were the
very first demigods and that line of
children was known as the golden lineage
morget's rune says that he was a part of
this golden lineage and mo's grey rune
says that him and morgan are twins so it
makes sense that they're a part of the
lineage together however a curse
inflicted both of them omen babies born
of royalty do not have their horns cut
but instead are kept underground and
imprisoned for eternity it seems that
they were permanently chained as we can
find an item called market shackle which
is a small part of a few larger shackles
that were made to bind margaret morgot
once again also known as margat was
cursed but it seems like he didn't hold
any ill will against the golden order as
despite never being loved by anyone he
still continued to give out his own love
and become the urgery's protector as for
his twin during his imprisonment mo was
sought out by someone only known as the
formless mother the formless mother is
an outer god similar to the greater will
but with more sinister plans he by the
will of the formless mother was
attempting to make mykola the new ruler
of the lands between he would then rule
as his consort and the formless mother
would then be able to control the lands
between just as the greater will can now
mikala and melania once again were twins
born from ratigan and america and since
they're the same person this fit within
the rules of them being an emperian this
explains why mo wants mikala as the
ruler and not himself because he isn't
an emperian according to more item
descriptions the formless mother only
seeks out those of a cursed blood which
is why he was chosen it also seems like
he couldn't just make mykola become the
ruler right away because mikala hasn't
achieved full godhood yet it's unclear
why but it could be related to mycola's
own curse something we'll discuss a bit
later getting back on track after
margaret we can meet with godric the
grafted godric grows to power through
the act of grafting according to rajir
he states that there are tarnished
hunters in this castle that will take
our corpse to godric so that we can be
grafted to him it's clear that godric
ruled his castle with fear as not many
would dare oppose him out of fear of
becoming a part of him so it's quite
hilarious when you return to his arena
and find one of his servants kicking his
corpse repeatedly dodric was a feeble
old man with no real power but he wanted
to prove to the others that he deserved
the title of lord by using fear and
manipulation to get his way but it's
quite obvious that he's bluffing as
without the grafting he's barely even a
competent fighter our next boss we meet
is the lady ranala queen of the full
moon the academy of rai lucario was at
odds with a group called the carrion
royal family both practiced different
versions of glenstone magic and
attempted to be the better sorcerers but
due to the age of the urge tree many of
its residents in the lands between found
power and hope in the golden order
making glinstone sorcery useless the
royal family then withered away during
this time and so did the academy but it
wasn't until the shattering that the
academy had a resurgence in power in her
youth ronaldo became a prominent
champion who charmed the academy with
her lunar magic she also commanded the
glenstone knights and established the
house of karya as royalty however
despite being a champion and a renowned
sorceress she became heartbroken thanks
to rat again leaving her she then became
a shell of her former self and it was
only then that the academy members
discovered that she wasn't a champion
after all later the academy would then
rebel against the karyan royal family
then lock her away in the grand library
shortly after this the shattering would
occur so the academy was permanently
locked down as no one wanted to
participate in the shattering so they
were left out of the destruction upon
entering the grand library we can see a
ton of kids as well as lady ranala
holding an amber egg in her arms after
defeating her first phase ronnie starts
speaking saying that we're trespassing
and are not allowed to disturb her as we
know ronnie is the daughter of ranala
but this doesn't make a whole lot of
sense though as ronnie is an imperian
who was born from two parents which
leads me to believe that ranala is the
adoptive mother and not the birth mother
of ronnie regarding this whole sequence
i also think this was a spell casted by
ronnie just in case anyone had
intentions of harming ranala not only is
the boss arena completely different but
right after defeating her again we can
see that she is just lying on the ground
this leads me to believe that this spell
was an illusion made by ronnie so that
she could protect her that egg she
carries however is the last thing ever
given to her by ratigan before he left
it seems to also have the power of
rebirth so either she is holding on to
this item because he gave it to her and
it's quite precious to her or she's
possibly waiting for the eventual
rebirth of ratigan through this egg i
hope it's not the latter as that wish
won't come true since ratigan is clearly
alive regardless of its significance
it's clear that ronaldo still hasn't
gotten over her ex-husband and has been
ruined because of it she is no longer
the queen of the full moon and is barely
even a sorcerer anymore during her boss
fight the kids are actually more
troublesome than she is with her only
attack being the occasional chandelier
falling after fending off the illusion
we then can return to ranala who gives
up her great rune and offers us a chance
to respect our stats seeing as we have
the great rune and she is clearly in no
state to fight there's no reason to kill
her so we just let her live our third
boss is radon who resides in khalid a
land that has been infested with scarlet
rock thanks to melania and her curse
radon is considered a champion of the
shattering and may have one of the best
backstories in this whole game when
radon was younger he looked up to
godfrey as he loved how strong he was in
battle so when radon was able to wear
his own personal armor he had a chess
piece made with a line on the front to
symbolize godfrey's beast region siraj
he also looked up to his father who was
proud of his accomplishments so he grew
out his long red hair and wore it with
pride as he grew older he started taking
after these two figures in his life and
wanted to become as strong as they were
but whether it was because of genetics
or the amount of strength he received
during this he started growing in size
this troubled him as due to his size and
weight he wouldn't be able to ride his
horse that he's had for his whole life
so he went to cela in caled which is
called the town of sorcery it was there
where he learned gravitational magic and
was able to manipulate the ground around
him and be able to call swords to his
hands but more importantly he was also
able to affect his own body weight
meaning he could ride his horse without
crushing it we know this not only
because we can see him do many attacks
while using gravity but the symbol for
gravity magic is the same symbol on his
swords furthermore it's known that the
elden ring commands the stars just as it
commands the other concepts of the world
like life and death but general radon is
considered the star scourge and seems to
be able to control the stars this is
because the cutscene after his death has
all the previous stars held in the sky
by him come crashing down one of which
actually lands right near us causing a
massive explosion but the difference
between general radon and many of the
other boss fights is that it's not a
normal boss fight as upon entering
caledon making our way to the back of
the castle we can see that there is
other people here blaith and alexander
are here assuming you met with them
prior as well as other characters we may
meet in the future like okina lionel and
target the reason they are here is
because they're all participating in the
radon festival a once in a lifetime
opportunity where you can face general
radon in battle and claim his great rune
we can summon all these people to fight
with us including many people who
weren't there for the festival such as a
finger maiden and even patches the
organizer of the festival gives us a
backstory of radon and his current state
is not too great if you recall from an
old trailer melania and radon fought at
this very place well during this fight
melania pierced radon injecting scarlet
rot into his body do you remember
earlier when i said that the twins were
cursed well whereas mickela is cursed to
an eternal childhood never becoming
anything older than a boy melania is
cursed by being forced to harbor a rot
with inside her body all the rot in
caled is most likely because of her we
can see the effect that it has on her
face in limbs but when we get to phase
two of the boss fight we can not only
see how much of her body's been affected
but also how much control she has over
this disease getting back to radon she
ended up using this rot to corrupt him
now he is just a blood-hungry beast but
the only thing on his mind about what
his next meal is going to be and what
the next kill will be this festival
seems to have been created by radon
himself or by an organizer trying to
help radon jiren is the name of the
organizer here at the castle and after
defeating radon he thanks us for the
fight as not only was that a spectacular
battle but we were able to give radon
his final wish which was to die an
honorable death he couldn't stand the
current state he was living in and
wanted someone to end his life but it
would be dishonorable for a general like
him to die from suicide or surrender so
an honorable fight to the death was the
only way for him to feel at peace but
now that general radon is dead there is
only one rune left prater reichard is a
unique case in the world of the lands
between he lies at the bottom of mount
gelmere the location of the most
appalling battle in the shattering
reicherd committed the grave sin of
blasphemy he spoke out against the
golden order as he was bothered by the
greater will and the golden order's
willingness to just cast aside those
deemed unworthy for no reason many
people would flock to reichard in his
castle the volcano manor but people
started having doubts about his decision
a spirit near the castle is seen atop a
pile of bodies in pain and says that if
he had known that this blasphemy would
have caused this much destruction he
wouldn't have tolerated his decision
given that many of those in the land
between believe in the golden order it's
quite obvious why many would hate riker
and his followers as they're actively
going against what they preach this
probably led to many crusades against
reichard which negatively impacted the
livelihoods of all his people upon
entering the manor we can meet tanith
she then asks us if we've ever harbored
any doubts about the guidance of grace
and the golden order and if we do say
yes then she'll invite us to the volcano
manor family she goes on to explain that
the tarnish were blessed with grace like
everyone else in the lands between but
it's clear that the tarnish didn't get
their fair share record refused to bow
down to this and believes that if the
urgery would debase them then they're
willing to go against the golden order
even if it's considered heresy so as a
member our job is to seek out those who
are aligned with the urge tree and the
golden order this is in the form of a
few npcs we are tasked with invading but
the manor also gives us a recusant
finger which allows us to invade other
players worlds so all the players we
invade are technically the tarnish he
speaks of which is why we're tasked with
eliminating them after a few contracts
have been completed upon coming back we
see a spirit sitting in the corner he's
preaching to the manor and hope someone
will heed his words he wants us to
eliminate the great serpent the one who
devoured prater reichard seeing as it
was him against the whole kingdom since
everyone disagreed with him and
continued to align with the golden order
printer record required more powers that
he may fight on an even level this is
when he met the great serpent it seems
that the serpent promised him power as
long as record was willing to be eaten
by him record agreed and became the
lord's serpent thankfully this spirit
has given us a way to defeat him by
letting us know of the power that
resides in the serpent hunter a weapon
specifically designed to kill the
serpent the fight is quite trivial with
this weapon as it should be but during
his second phase he pulls out a sword
and as we can see from the weapon it has
moving hands which were all from his
previous victims it's quite sad to think
about all the people in their past lives
and accomplishments now being withered
down to nothing as now they're just a
part of the serpent family stuck in this
hell forever we can actually talk to
some of the members of the volcano
matter after defeating reichert and none
of them seem upset bernal believes that
the strong take in the weak suffer so by
killing him we proved that reichard was
weak tyneth even agrees and thanks us
for showing them how weak a record
really was the only problem is that
record's immortal it just takes time for
him to get back to full strength and
should we return to the boss arena we
can see record's body repairing itself
while taneth holds him so it seems that
riker will eventually come back how long
that will take is unknown but just like
before we have the great rune so
currently our job is done with all the
great runes in our possession we can
travel to lindell the royal capital and
go to the erd tree here is where we meet
numerous knights and tree sentinels
truly showing how powerful this army
really is there is also a one-to-one
version of the round table hold in here
this is most likely the real round table
and the one we're taken to is just a
copy since the shattering ruined much of
the land and caused this residence to
close off its walls as we remember only
certain people can enter the round table
it's not a building that people can just
waltz right into which may explain why
on the map the round table hold is off
to the very side symbolizing that it's
separate than the one in the lands
between on top of this since we made it
to the capitol melania leaves our side
since we fulfilled our deal and brought
her to the urgery but when we ourselves
get close to the urgery godfrey attempts
to stop us this is clearly a spirit
version of him and it's possible given
the golden color that it's godfrey's
remembrance from during the war before
he was tarnished all the remembrances we
gather in game are memories of the
bosses and these memories are all a part
of the erd tree later in the game we
will actually end up fighting godfrey in
his actual form but when we defeat him
he drops the remembrance of horolu not
the remembrance of godfrey which leads
me to my previous conclusion after him
is when we meet morgot and since we
already discussed him quite a bit i
won't repeat myself however he does let
us know who the thrones are for which
was godric michela melania radon
reichard and ronnie he also calls them
all traitors which is quite interesting
i think it's because morget believes
that they are fighting so they can claim
the power of the elven ring for
themselves and become the new elden lord
but morgot being the protector of the
urgery finds this a disgraceful act as
it's clear that they only really care
about the power that comes with the
elven lore title and not about
protecting the earth tree and the golden
order after defeating morget we can talk
to him momentarily and he calls us a
fool saying that the urge tree doesn't
open for anyone and that no one will be
able to claim the title of elden lord
and it seems that morgot himself tried
to attempt this and wasn't allowed
inside to prove his statement we walk up
the steps and discover we can't enter
the earth tree has rejected us the year
tree is covered by impassable thorns
that cannot be cut melinda then arrives
again and explains to be elden lord we
must pass through the thorns and the
only way to burn them is to go to the
snowy mountaintops of the giants and use
its smoldering flame to set the er tree
on fire we can then talk to the finger
reader back at the round table hold to
get more insight on this and she goes on
to explain that because of this sudden
turn of events which is us being
rejected by the urgery the two fingers
is currently consulting with the greater
will but we likely won't get an answer
for thousands of years we then tell her
our immediate plan to burn the thorns
and is shocked by the idea claiming that
the snowy mountains is not a place for
mere men and that burning the earth tree
is the first cardinal sin something the
fingers and the greater will will never
agree to furthermore we then explain our
next step in the process which is to
unleash the rune of death when we make
it to the highest point in the mountains
we talk with melana who tells us that
she will be the kindling required to
burn the tree earlier the finger reader
told us that this ritual requires a
sacrifice and melano is willing to be
that sacrifice before she disappears
though she does deliver a few words and
goes on to say that throughout her life
she has seen death and discrimination
everywhere convincing her that the lands
between is in dire need of repair this
sort of implies that she has lived quite
a long life something that connects to a
theory of mine later in the game as we
touch hands once more she takes our
power and uses it and the smoldering
flames nearby to create a flame big
enough to set her and the tree ablaze
afterwards we wake up in pharah missoula
not much is known about this place but i
believe this was the temple in the sky
throughout the lands between are ruins
of a fallen city the ruined fragments we
pick up are believed to be a part of a
temple in the sky and the only place in
game that fits that description would be
pharah missoula as we explore the area
we run into the beast clergyman again
the same one in khalid who we give the
death route to assuming you've followed
through with that quest line he then
attacks us since we are clearly here to
steal the rune of death from him and he
doesn't want it stolen again this is a
nice piece of foreshadowing as soon
after defeating him he reveals his true
form to be malakath the black blade the
shadow of america and the owner of the
rune of death now it makes sense why we
were feeding him death through during
his questline as the description reads
after the death of godwin the rune of
death spread across the lands between
through the underground roots of the
great tree sprouting in the form of
death root malakath being the owner of
the rune of death would obviously want
his power back so by consuming the death
root we are giving it back to him upon
his death a weird object sprouts from
his shadowy ashes this is the rune of
death and because it's unbound the lands
between are now shrouded in a dark fate
and the greater will is not happy about
that we pass out again and awake in
lindell but now it's covered in ashes it
seems like we have a straight path to
the earth tree now but nothing is ever
simple in this game blocking our path is
gideon and godfrey gideon appears in
godfrey's chamber and the long-awaited
fight ensues gideon and us have been
gunning for the elden lord position all
game so it was only a matter of time
before we faced off together except
that's not what's happening gideon
immediately says that nobody will become
the elden lord and that america has
plans for all of us and that plan being
that we struggle for eternity so why
this sudden change of heart gideon
during his journey to obtain all
knowledge may have uncovered some
details about merica that changed his
mind the all-knowing helmet description
reads knowledge begins with the
recognition of one's ignorance the
realization that the search of knowledge
is unending but when gideon glimpsed
into the will of queen america he
shuddered in fear at the end that should
not be something terrified gideon so
much that completely changed his mind
about being the elden lord my guess was
most likely the relationship between the
greater will and merica or maybe even
the elven beast as well as for godfrey
he appears in normal human form this
time and we can see him holding more god
in his arms godfrey then spots us and
recognizes us immediately as the
tarnished warrior the one who's been
conquering many before him godfrey wants
to obtain the elden lord title again and
since that conflicts with our goals we
have to fight him after half his health
is gone he uses suraj to gain more power
and reveals that his true form is horulu
the chieftain of the badlands when
godfrey and the other tarnished had been
forced out of the lands between this act
was called the long march and when the
long march had finished godfrey and the
other tarnished had started their own
civilization and it was during this time
that godfrey possibly wanted to cut all
ties away from him in the lands between
so he adopted the name horuleu however
with god free finished nothing stands in
our way when we enter the room we see
merica chained to a part of the elven
ring but eventually she breaks free but
her hair turns red and we realize that
radigan is now in control it seems to me
that their bodies change when one takes
control as merika and ratigan seem to
have different physiques when viewed up
close like america having a skinnier
body in the absence of breasts when
radigan is in control this may not be
entirely true however since it's quite
hard to look at their bodies while
you're being attacked but this at least
confirms that there are two people in
one body however we still don't know if
they were two separate people that then
became one or if it was always one body
to begin with after the fight is over
ratigan starts becoming engulfed in a
black mist as a hand reaches out and
takes him underneath the pool of sludge
out of this sludge arises the elden
beast probably one of the coolest
looking bosses in the soulsborne
franchise we've already discussed the
elden beast in detail earlier but as a
reminder the elden beast is the vassal
for the greater will and is the living
embodiment of the concept of order but
the question is why are we fighting
ratigan and the elden beast in the first
place remember the point of our journey
was to become the elden lord and be a
consort for america so why are they
killing the one person who was able to
fill that role one is possibly due to
the fact that we are tarnished and even
attempting to become elden lord does go
against the golden order but it may also
have to do with the greater will and a
secret agenda that it has it's clear
that the greater will wants america as
the ruler of the lands between and to
have the elden ring repaired to the
golden order can be stable again but
since that stalemate occurred it needed
help which is why i called the tarnish
back to the lands between the greater
will more than likely had a plan in mind
but since we burned the urgery and
unbound the rune of death it most likely
casted all of that aside and just opted
to kill us as we committed a cardinal
sin regardless of its intentions the
elven beast is defeated and the greater
will seems to have no power over the
lands between anymore it's unclear
whether or not the greater will is truly
dead though or if its power is truly
gone as the elden beast is just a vassal
for the greater will which is much
different than a vessel america is a
vessel for the elden ring whereas the
elden beast is a vassal for the greater
will so it acts in accordance to the
greater will's wishes so i think the
greater will still does exist in some
way but doesn't really have as much
control over the lens betweens as it
used to with the elden beast slain we
now reach the ending of the game and
it's here where i have to be a bit
honest with all of you i don't know all
the endings of elden ring and depending
on when you watch this video you don't
either despite what many believe there
is in fact more than four endings in the
game and at the time of making this
video there is a total of six confirmed
endings with a seven still under
investigation i normally don't make
these videos until everything has been
discovered so we can get the full
picture but this could take an
undetermined amount of time to figure
out so if you'll forgive me i'd like to
discuss these endings with all of you
anyway so the very first ending is the
default one that all players will be
able to obtain which is the age of
fracture this shows the player mending
the body and runes back together and
becoming the elden lord like we set out
to do the lands between seems to go back
to normal but is a fractured version of
what it once was thanks to the
shattering and all the demi-gods we slid
on our path here the next three endings
are all tied to character quests and are
the same ending but with slight
alterations in two different places the
age of duskborn is from fia's questline
where we use the mending rune of the
death prince she provides us at the end
of her questline as a way to mend all
the runes back together but instead of
it being a normal looking pattern the
curse mark appears at the bottom and
instead of a normal looking sky there's
a grey mist that covers the land this
seems to imply that the rune of death is
back in the elden ring which hasn't
happened since before america's reign
meaning the death will come to the lands
between once more and immortality is a
thing of the past the blessing of
despair is the third version of this
ending and is activated upon completion
of the dung eater questline and using
the mending rune of the fel curse which
leaves a sizable clump of disease on
america's body the land once again
changes but to a brown and reddish tint
and possibly implies that the dung eater
got his wish he has a dream of blessing
the people with a curse that starts with
all the people he's defiled and killed
they will then be reborn and create
children who harbor their curse and
those children will have their own
children who harbor that curse until
everyone is afflicted by it the fourth
variation of this ending that we know of
is the age of order which is done by
completing brother corin and the gold
mass quest line where on the body of the
gold mask will be the mending rune of
perfect order needed to complete this
ending just as before it's the exact
same ending with the same differences
this rune is of a transcensional
ideology that will attempt to perfect
the golden order this is symbolized in
the pattern being the same as before but
with a large circle around it as for the
differences the sky seems to be the same
golden color but now the erd tree is
golden once again our last two endings
are different from the ones we have
discussed so far the lord of frenzied
flame is the opposite of the other
endings that we just discussed where the
tarnish will become the lord of chaos
they then burn the erd tree and most
likely leave the lands between to do
this you must complete the quest route
of the three fingers which ends with the
three fingers grabbing and marking you
however depending on when you do this
another cutscene will play it's done
after melina sacrifices herself then the
ending plays out like normal but if
you're marked upon arriving melina
leaves your side and promises that if
you go down this path she will have no
choice but to hunt you down now if you
choose this ending every other ending is
locked unless you use an item called
michela's needle which reverts the
marking allowing you to choose the other
endings again this is why she mentions
that part about going down the current
path is we do have the option to change
our mind but assuming we don't and
melanin knows that we're marked a second
cutscene will play where melina grabs
what is presumed to be the whistle we
use to summon torrent and then vows to
hunt us down we also see that her left
eye is now open and has a purple color
to it whereas the right eye that is used
to be yellow is now faded this has led
many to believe including me that melano
in some way is related to ronnie in the
story trailer for the game ronnie is
seen with the right eye closed then the
left one open and the spirit form next
to her has her left eye shut and the
right eye open but it's the same eye
which is the trailer possibly telling us
that these two beings are related and
the only person with her left eye shut
throughout the game is melana this could
also explain why melina seemingly
appears wherever we are as the spirit
form she is just able to teleport in and
out of existence the final ending is
called the age of stars and it's
available upon the completion of
ronnie's questline we summon ronnie from
inside the archery where she then picks
up and places america's head onto her
body just like we have done in the
previous endings she then goes on to
make a promise to all the living beings
and souls that exist in the world and
says that the age of stars has commenced
and that the one thousand year voyage
underneath the wisdom of the moon is
about to begin possibly meaning that the
people are no longer bound by the forces
of a god and can act on their own free
will we then become her spouse and she
becomes the new ruler but you may be
asking how was that possible as while
ronnie was an empyrean she claimed to
have stripped away her impurian flesh so
that can't make her a ruler well there
is a lot to unpack with this ending and
is quite difficult to interpret given
how little we actually have to go off of
but it seems that ronnie wants to have
the moon and stars under control again
as it's possible this was the large
governing force of the world before the
greater will arrived this would make
sense given that she wanted to break
away from her imperium body and since
the greater will is out of the picture
this concept of empyreans is unnecessary
now this is what leads me to my previous
conclusion that the people of the world
will no longer be bound by the influence
of a higher power and can think on their
own these are all the endings we have so
far the seventh one dubbed the age of
absolute is still under investigation
others are also trying to figure out if
it's possible to do the age of star
ending with melanes still alive just to
see if something changes since of course
the growing theory is that they are
related however at the time of making
this video none of this has gotten
anywhere so we'll have to wait and see
with that however we come to the end of
elven ring and subsequently the end of
the video the amount of lore in the
soulsborne games is astronomical and
trying to catalog all of it then repeat
it to an audience is incredibly
challenging but i think i did a good job
providing a clear and simple timeline of
events for all of you feel free to watch
any of my other story explained videos
on different games in the industry or if
you prefer to listen to a review rather
than a retelling i made a few videos
discussing the stories of specific games
like the bioshock series and fallout 4
that you may enjoy with that like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe if
you're new and thank you as always to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you